you as somebody that I don't know but
you taking shots at me like it's virtual
it is here you guys Taylor Swift just
dropped the music video for you need to
calm down and it has about 1 billion
famous people in it including a much
anticipated cameo from Katy Perry I'm
just like hey are you ok
nope we are not ok it's too good so
let's break it down
[Music]
first up that's dancer Dexter Mayfield
working it to the beat looking fab in
pink Laverne Cox and Chester Lockhart
and there's Hannah Hart pumping some
iron Taylor skips down the road with her
pal todrick Hall
that's Hayley kiyoko hitting the
bullseye and my personal fave Jesse
Tyler Ferguson and his hubby Justin
Makita kissing at the altar could be
good and yes that is Ciara serving as
the officiant next up queer eyes Fab
five tan Bobby coram Oh Antony and
Jonathan don't blink or you'll miss
everyone's favorite Olympian Adam rip on
handing out snow cones Ellen DeGeneres
also made an appearance that's her
getting a tattoo from Adam Lambert fans
wondered at the 61 year olds would
appear in Taylor's video after this
moment on Ellen's daytime talk show in
May and then you have another video
coming out soon ish yeah when is it
coming out I don't know yet cuz we have
to finish it first okay yeah and then uh
I think you said you wanted me in it
yeah I mean that would be a dream yeah
would you want to do that hmm I don't
know but
I think about it okay for sure do ya
okay right okay let's get back to it
shall we
Billy Porter strutted for the camera and
some of drag races biggest stars
channeled their inner pop divas tatyana
as ariana grande Trinity the Tuck as
Gaga Delta work as Adele Trinity K Bonet
as cardi B Jade Jolie as Taylor adore
delano as Katy Perry
a curious Chanel Davenport as Nicki
Minaj the only girl in the lineup who
didn't come off the hit show was Riley
Knox who slayed as Beyonce naturally the
og RuPaul made a cameo to
[Music]
[Applause]
Ryan Reynolds popped up for a hot SEC
and the moment we've all been waiting
for
that's Katy Perry donning her hamburger
dress from the Met Gala after party and
there's Taylor dressed as french fries
the two hold hands sway back and forth
and even hug seemingly squashing their
years long feud on Monday Katie shared
this shot on Instagram with the caption
this meal is beef free the feelgood's
you guys they're like next-level in this
video and it's literally everything I
hoped it would be and more and at the
end of the video Taylor encourages her
fans to sign her petition for Senate
support of the Equality Act I love it in
May Taylor teased that her new music
would have quote political undertones
telling German outlet DPA quote I'm not
planning to stop encouraging young
people to vote and to try to get them to
talk about what's going on in our
country I think that's one of the most
important things I could do I see you
and I feel what you're doing Taylor of
course et will be here to keep you
up-to-date on all of Taylor's new music
as it drops so make sure to keep it
locked right here on ET until next time
I'm Holly Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]